[Music]
on this Monday night Canada's new cap on
International students we're very
worried that it's too broad a brush how
long the limit will last the problems
it's supposed to solve and the potential
repercussions Dementia in Canada how
it's expected to become more common in
people under age
65 he was a master Craftsman it's very
difficult to make films the loss of
Canadian movie making genius Norman Jew
listen and when politics collides with
prayers the controversy over this new
Hindu temple in India plus tall order
bito Bonito the giraffe's long journey
to greener
pastures global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us the federal government is
putting a temporary cap on the number of
international students allowed to come
to Canada it's an attempt to try to ease
the pressure on strained Public Services
the number of international student
permits will be reduced by 35% the cap
means roughly 364,000 permits will be
issued this year that's down from
560,000 in 2023 since 2014 the number of
foreign students in Canada has been
steadily increasing and there has been a
significant jump since the pandemic
there are now more than a million study
permit holders in Canada the government
says it's targeting so-called Bad actors
private colleges that charge High
tuition for lowquality education and it
wants to ease pressure on Health Care
and housing Abigail Beeman explains the
plan and the reaction in our top story
tonight once they graduate will they be
able to do something zad G grew up in
Dubai and earned his bachelor's degree
at Carlton University in Ottawa now he's
a banker he's frustrated the new cap
could limit opportunities for other
foreign students most of them have came
from countries that are going through
struggles they're looking for a new
future over here and apparently the
minister does not want to give them the
chance claiming that it's because of the
housing allowing Bad actors to continue
their operations would be a disservice
to all the good institutions who Pride
themselves in providing a top tier
academic experience the immigration
Minister calls these blunt measures
aimed at the schools putting profits
ahead of Education Masters and PhD
students are exempt the housing Minister
says we can expect more moves to tackle
the housing crisis but believes this
will help in certain pockets of the
country of the Peele region for example
uh you may end up seeing a bit of an
alleviation of the pressure that people
have seen as a result of the significant
in flux of international students over
the past few years the growth in
international students one of the
economists advising cabinet at the
Montreal Retreat thinks the cap will
reduce pressure on both rental and owner
markets overnight investors say you know
what the uh the student Market doesn't
doesn't look as attractive as it did
before we're going to lower uh we're
going to start buying up fewer homes and
that's going to create places for
first-time home buyers to to buy
immediately some in the education sector
applaud the second part of Monday's
announcement new limits on work permits
after graduation while worrying about
maligning International students within
the overall cap especially in more
populous provinces Ontario's numbers
will be cut by as much as 50% we're very
worried that it's too broad a brush with
how it's being used we need uh skilled
labor to build houses and we don't have
enough of it in Canada it's really
important that we don't scapegoat
International students as being the
cause of the problem the immigration
minister is aware of those concerns and
says he'll work with provinces looking
for exemptions for some trade schools of
course so much of this is up to the
provinces and will come out in the
details how and where to hand out their
allotted numbers Donna Abigail Bean in
Montreal thanks Abigail there's a new
snap shot of how Alzheimer's and
Dementia is affecting Canadians while
age is the strongest risk factor the
Alzheimer Society of Canada says one
demographic is being overlooked younger
adults young onset dementia is the term
used when symptoms develop in people
under the age of 65 using computer
models the Alzheimer's Society predicts
by the year 2050 there could be over
40,000 people under 65 living with
dementia in Canada a lack of awareness
about young onset dementia can lead to
things like delayed diagnosis Katherine
Ward explains the impact that can have
from my perspective she is my life I
will do anything for her Pasha keshi is
talking about his wife Ruby their
marriage of more than 45 years has stood
the test of time this is my Early
Childhood three children and eight
grandchildren are their most treasured
Joys but there have been recent
unexpected challenges it was a bombshell
for us 3 years ago at the age of 64 Ruby
was diagnosed with Alzheimer's disease
her uncle and father had also lived with
the disease I knew what's going going to
be happen to me and I had everything
very clear so I decided that not to get
frustrated what it is it is I have to
figure out how to deal with it anyone
under the age of 65 who receives a
diagnosis has what's referred to as
young onset dementia approximately 3% of
the people living with dementia in
Canada fall into this category it's also
also not recognized by the healthcare
system as well if you're say 55 and you
develop some cognitive impairments might
not be clear that you immediately need
to think about is this dementia that's
affecting this individual 28,000 people
under age 65 were living with dementia
in 2020 as more about the disease is
uncovered that number is projected to
reach more than 40 ,000 by the year 2050
according to the Alzheimer Society of
Canada the opportunity that we're given
now is to be proactive we need to
recognize identify those people who are
who should have a diagnosis so we can
provide the supports and the education
so they can live well with dementia Ruby
now makes notes for herself and keeps to
a routine together she and her husband
are determined to face the diagnosis
headon side by side he my life she said
that I'm not going
anywhere so we help each
other Katherine Ward Global
News police in Ontario say they've
recovered 52 stolen vehicles worth more
than $3.2 million and 11 people are now
facing 96 charges police say the group
targeted high-end vehicles and intended
to traffic them as far away as aeran and
Georgia the vehicles were stolen across
Southern in Ontario and then stored in
residential areas vehicle theft is on
the rise especially in Quebec and
Ontario in the US there is a showdown
shaping up in New Hampshire a pivotal
primary that could be Nikki Haley's last
chance to prevent Donald Trump from
becoming the Republican Presidential
nominee and it's a joy for me to be able
to say to you ladies and gentlemen the
next president of the United States
Nikki
haly that was Judge Judy delivering her
verdict last night she is campaigning
for Haley Trump though has drained the
political life out of all his Rivals and
now it's a contest between him and Haley
Jackson prco is in New Hampshire
tonight the crowds still come to see
Donald
Trump lining up for hours in the bitter
cold to hear from a man with an
unshakable grip on his party I really
feel like Trump is the only one that can
potentially change the ENT entire
trajectory of where things are going
right now in New Hampshire Trump's front
runner status is hardly in question his
supporters wonder why there's a primary
race at all I am hoping that Trump kills
it like he did last time I think he's
going to do very very well to be
honest on the trail Trump seems like a
man who isn't worried much about winning
we will soon be taking the oath of
office on the steps of the United States
capital on the other side of the state
at a rally for Nikki Haley she gives me
hope a different group of Republicans
believes this is still a fight for the
party and the country Governor Haley is
one of the best people that have ever
run for the presidency of the United
States Haley's supporters include
moderate Republicans and yes even
Democrats who just want a trump
alternative America doesn't do
coronations we believe in choices
we believe in democracy and we believe
in Freedom do well enough in New
Hampshire and she can keep up the fight
a poor showing could hand the nomination
to Trump almost immediately we started
this as an anti-trump organization
that's why Progressive groups are
pushing New Hampshire's large base of
independent voters to back Haley in the
primary it's better for our country if
it's a if it's a Haley Biden race where
you have two candidates committed to
democracy toppling Trump is is no small
task even if Haley does the impossible
here the states that come after New
Hampshire will be tougher to win there's
a new dynamic in Tuesday's primary now
that Ronda santis has dropped out of the
race his supporters are more likely to
back Trump making it that much harder
for Nikki Haley to achieve the
Breakthrough she's been looking for in
New Hampshire Donna Jackson in
Manchester New Hampshire thanks Jackson
there are reports Israel is proposing a
two-month pause in fighting in Gaza as
part of a multiphase deal deal with
Hamas that would include the release of
all remaining hostages The Proposal said
to be handled by mediators from qar and
Egypt has not been confirmed by either
side military operations have
intensified in Han Yunis in southern
Gaza explosions and gunfire could be
heard throughout that city as Israeli
tanks moved around buildings there are
reports a hospital there has been
surrounded the Hamas run Health Ministry
says more than 25,000 Palestinians many
of them women and children have been
killed in Gaza since the conflict
began and families of some of the more
than 130 hostages in Gaza broke through
security and stormed into a committee
meeting in Israel's parliament today
they're demanding the government do more
to get their loved ones released some of
them carrying signs saying you will not
sit here while they die out there
families have also been rallying outside
prime minister Benjamin netanyahu's
home Netanyahu has repeatedly refused to
consider the idea of a two-state
solution he's facing growing pressure to
reconsider today at a meeting in
Brussels EU foreign ministers added to
calls for the creation of a Palestinian
State saying it is the only path to
peace they say Israel's plan to destroy
Hamas is not working and that it is
seeding hate for
Generations the US and Britain launched
a new wave of military strikes on houy
militants disrupting commercial shipping
in the Red Sea earlier today the Danish
shipping giant MK said it is diverting
its container service away from the Red
Sea in response to heightened security
risks the company says the situation is
volatile and its vessels will be
re-rooted taking the long way around the
Cape of Good Hope in South Africa
Canadian director Norman jewison has
died his publicist says he passed away
peacefully on Saturday he was 97 years
old old the acclaimed filmmaker was
behind the lens for celebrated movies
such as In the Heat of the Night Moon
struck and Fiddler on the Roof Tonight
Eric Sorenson looks back at jewson's
storytelling
Legacy Norman can you get a photo he was
not the most recognizable public figure
but in Hollywood Norman jewison was
royalty he won the Academy Awards most
prestigious honor the Irving thalberg
award because he made so many films that
were inspired in and important it's
called paying your dues I mean um it's
very difficult to make films it's very
difficult they were difficult but
memorable he directed In the Heat of the
Night to the Oscar for best film was Mr
cobbert ever in this greenhouse say last
night about
midnight that was called the most
important slap in Hollywood history
jewison showing a black detective from
Philadelphia standing up to the long
accepted racism in the 1960s Amer ameran
South I saw
it but what are you going to do about
it I don't know to jewison it was a
natural reaction it was one of those
things which which had to be
instinctual because Sydney was playing a
a detective jewson's film making was
instinctual searching for the innate
truth in the stories he told whether a
comedy that made light of the Cold War
or a point musal about Jewish
[Music]
peasants Fiddler on the Roof garnered
Json one of his three Oscar nominations
for Best Director not bad for a
Protestant kid from Toronto he started
in the early days of Television
directing TV shows in Canada and the US
he would go on to work with the biggest
stars in the world his films an iconic
exhibition of titles The Cincinnati Kid
The Thomas Crown Affair Jesus Christ
Superstar and in the hurricane he was of
course drawn to the story of Ruben
Hurricane Carter wrongly accused of
murder we're looking for two Negroes in
a white car any two will do I mean this
man spent 19 20 years in jail for
something he didn't do it's fill full of
courage and hope and inspiration among
his triumphs are Landmark films of
humanity along the way jewison coaxed
the best from temperamental stars from
Steve McQueen to to share do you love
him Loretta I love him awful oh God
that's too bad the great thing about
Norman as a director he says I cast you
therefore let me see what you surprise
me
okay a distinctly Canadian Legacy that
will live on is Jon's founding of the
Canadian Film Center near his farm north
of Toronto it's been developing the next
generation of movie makers for more than
three decades to build this
place and I'm so
grateful and
proud that we in Canada have done this
Json hoped what moved him would Inspire
future filmmakers so just tell stories
that move us to laughter in tears and
perhaps reveal a little truth about
ourselves the Norman jewison film making
wasn't about Fame and Fortune but simply
finding a good way to tell a good story
Eric Sorenson Global News
Toronto calls for Action in Nova Scotia
coming up a grieving mother's push to
improve the province's emergency alert
system the mother of six-year-old Colton
Cisco who died in flood waters in Nova
Scotia last summer wants changes to the
province's emergency alert system the
day her son died torrential rain was
causing flash floods it took nearly 2
hours for an alert to go out four people
were killed that day including cold
Heidi petrick spoke with his mom about
what she believes could make the
difference between life and death this
is Colton's room I have some stuff that
I've set out like his his little Timbits
Jersey Colton Cisco's bedroom is almost
as he left it the six-year-old died in
the pre-dawn hours of July 22nd swept
away as he and his father fled
floodwaters before an emergency alert
told residents to stay home an alert
that took officials close to two hours
to issue there's no need to keep the
public waiting in the
dark when their lives are at risk the
bodies of Colton and three others
including another child and a teen were
found by Searchers several days later
his mother terara Cisco has pushed the
province to speed up its alert process
ever since I'd like to see a first
responder being able to reach out to
someone who can go all right leave it
with me and I'll get it handled and it
will go out uh not a six-step system the
provincial government hasn't made any
changes yet it's not the first time Nova
scotia's alert system has come under
scrutiny After the flood the premier
directed the emergency management office
to ask communities and First Responders
what could improve speed is of course
important but uh making sure that
whatever changes are implemented uh
bring tangible benefits that's really
the focus we don't have two hours three
hours uh you know to to wait for that
alert to go out um you know we have 20
minutes sometimes not even that
volunteer firefighter Brett tannish
asked for the alert the night of the
flood as he responded to rescue calls
only to be left waiting he's also
disappointed The Province hasn't moved
more quickly still haunted by what
happened the amount of time it took for
that alert to go out
um I feel uh I feel that lives may not
have been lost if if the alert was out
in a timely manner I have moments where
I just want to cry all day and moments
where I'm like nope I gotta keep going
Cisco is dealing with her grief partly
by advocating for better emergency
preparedness in a campaign she's dubbed
Colton's call Heidi pic Global News Mart
talk Nova
Scotia ahead religious tension a Hindu
temple opens in India on a contested
holy
[Music]
site
there's Fanfare and controversy in India
over the opening of a new Hindu temple
prime minister Narendra Modi presided
over the event and his critics are
accusing him of stoking religious
tension the temple sits on top of the
ruins of a 16th century mosque once
again here's Eric
senson it's being compared with Mecca or
the Vatican the Rah Temple represents
the newest Shrine for more than 1
billion Hindus in India built on what
they believe is the birthplace of the
deity
Rah The Joy felt when Rah was born he
says we are feeling the very ecstasy the
temple was consecrated not by a
religious leader but by prime minister
Narendra Modi declaring our Lord Rah has
come Modi performed the rituals and made
a prayer offering at the feet of Lord
rah's Idol demonstrating the bond
between the state and Hinduism in a
country that until recent years had
celebrated religious diversity separated
from from politics it is the
politicization of a of a religious event
the full force of the state is behind
the consecration the construction of
this Temple and in that sense it it's
violates India's Constitution the
disputed site was once home to the Boby
mosque constructed by Muslims 500 years
ago but Hindu nationalists stormed the
mosque in 1992 reduced it to Rubble
hundreds of Muslims were killed their
homes destroyed in the days
after for Muslims who prayed nearby
today is one of
Despair everyone carries the grief of
the mosque being demolished says this
man the pain of that day will always be
fresh says another but as many Hindus
believe their own Shrine was their first
India's courts eventually approved
construction of the temple to have back
this Temple I think for India it's
something amazing the temple is not
finished but this early ceremony May
boost Narendra Mod's bid for reelection
this spring fueled by the intense
nationalism he's promoted many
democracies now are dealing with this
ethnonationalist movements and so this
is a great concern India matters because
it's the world's largest democracy the
fear among some is that today's ceremony
is just the beginning that nationalists
will try to create new temples on other
disputed sites with the government's
blessing Eric senson Global News Toronto
on the move next Bonito the giraffe
begins a long journey to a warmer
home a transport truck in Mexico began a
long journey today with some tall and
Precious
Cargo that extra tall container is
carrying Benito the giraffe the
four-year-old is being moved from a zoo
in Northern Mexico to a Conservation
Park much further south it's about a
2,000 km journey and it's expected to
take about 50 hours Bono's 5 m Tall
trailer was specially designed just for
him it has food water cameras and
temperature control the giraffe lived in
a small park near Mexico's northern
border where it gets cold in Winter and
very hot in summer his new home is being
described as more like the African
Savannah that is global national for
this Monday I'm Donna freezen tonight's
your candidate is Elk Island national
park near Fort Saskatchewan Alberta
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye